lange Schuhe Schließungen gesperrte
Spielplätze und Partys nur noch virtuell
das hat Deutschlands Kinder und
Jugendlichen schwer zugesetzt
Familienministerin dieser Pausen
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
haben dazu eine Studienauftrag gegeben
die Ergebnisse sind erschütternd 73% der
Kinder und Jugendlichen sind schwer
psychisch angeschlagen viele brauchen
professionelle Hilfe Psychiater
berichten sogar von suizidge Gedanken
bei unter zehnjährigen droht uns da eine
auf Dauer Geschädigte Generation hätte
man das verhindern können Herr Bonelli
sie sind bei uns vielleicht können Sie
uns einmal mitnehmen in den Alltag den
sie erleben als Psychiater in ihrer
Praxis was hat sich da verändert kommen
zu Ihnen Eltern die genau solche Themen
solche Sorgen um ihre Kinder haben
also ich habe ich habe Patienten mit den
verschiedensten Problemen und natürlich
hat Corona irgendwie das Klientel
verändert und zwar besonders leiden
Menschen glaube ich vor allem unter der
Spaltung der Gesellschaft also wie wir
miteinander umgehen also da ist wirklich
spürbar dass ich deine Veränderung
hergestellt hat also Menschen die nie in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft waren und
plötzlich Diskriminierung ausgegrenzt
wurden die Erfahrungen gemacht haben die
man eigentlich normalerweise nicht macht
oder die ich nur wirklich von sehr
speziellen Gruppen kenne also
Migrationshintergrund Juden zum Beispiel
ich habe sehr viele oder die
homosexuelle Menschen die das kennen
ausgegrenzt zu werden plötzlich sind das
Gruppen die ganz anders sind also die
die mitten in der mitten in der
Gesellschaft war also das spürt man und
wenn ich das jetzt hört von den Kindern
dann denke ich man hat natürlich auch
mit den Erwachsenen zu tun ja weil viele
Eltern waren extrem überfordert dass
ihre Kinder plötzlich zu Hause sind die
waren nervös die waren aggressiv und das
hat natürlich auf die Kinder dann auch
zurückgewirkt der allein dass ein Kind
nicht in die Schule gehen darf macht es
noch nicht das Kind depressiv sondern
die Frage ist was erlebt es dann zu
Hause
Suizidgedanken bei Kindern ich muss
sagen wenn ich mir sowas alleine zu
hören bricht mir das Herz das kann doch
nicht sein dass das jetzt die Folge ist
73 Prozent der Kinder und Jugendlichen
das ist so eine große Mehrheit die
psychisch leiden was glauben Sie was
waren die schrecklichsten Maßnahmen die
Maßnahmen die besonders große psychische
Schäden bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
hinterlassen für mich ist Psychiater war
die Maske ganz besonders dramatisch weil
sie die Kommunikation zwischen den
Menschen vor unmöglich hat und besonders
die Kinder brauchen ein ein
fürsorgliches gegenüber und wenn das
dann nur noch eine Maske ist die
vielleicht auch noch Angst hat und die
vielleicht von den Kindern weggrenzt die
die Kinder vielleicht das pestraten
beschimpft oder sowas dann glaube ich
ist klar dass diese Kinder gestört
werden gestört in ihrem Entwicklung also
das nehme ich schon ganz klar waren was
kann man tun um zu helfen was raten Sie
auch Eltern man kann vielleicht auch
viele Ängste erstmal gar nicht einordnen
oder versucht die erstmal zu überspielen
hauptsache man macht das Kind wieder
glücklich was raten sie Eltern die sich
da in besonderer Sorge befinden die
Frage ist richtig gestellt weil wenn ein
Kind ein Problem hat dann ist das
meistens ein systemisches Problem das
heißt es hat mit den Eltern zu tun hat
mit den Geschwistern zu tun und man
musste also wenn man von außen ist
Therapeut kommt muss man schauen dass
wieder Ruhe im System kommt das wieder
ein Frieden herrscht weil auch innerhalb
der Familien kann es ja zu diesen
Spaltungen zu diesen Verurteilungen ich
habe immer wieder mit Patienten geredet
die gesagt haben ich werde von der
Großfamilie nicht eingeladen weil ich
nicht ungeimpft bin zum Beispiel solche
Sachen das müssen wir es auch arbeiten
da muss es Versöhnung geben da muss man
sich da muss man sich auch entschuldigen
solche Sachen müssen passieren und den
und den Kindern gegenüber muss man
müssen die Eltern glaube ich für Frieden
sorgen also gerade wenn die Eltern
miteinander im Streit liegen dann leiden
die Kinder meistens und hier ist viel zu
tun
viel zu tun viele Fehler die dann auch
einfach gar nicht mehr ungeschehen
machen kann frau Loth viele Menschen
haben gelitten auch ältere die dann
einsam und alleine in Heimen sterben
mussten keine Familienmitglieder dürften
mehr zu ihnen bisher haben sie in dieser
Zeit gelitten also es ist ja so ich habe
meine Eltern paar Monate lang nicht
gesehen ja und weil ich aufgrund weil
ich einen schweren Verlauf hatte und
mit Lungenentzündung sie haben alles
damals mitbekommen und es ist ja jetzt
so dass meine Eltern ich bin zweimal die
Woche da ich mache deren Einkäufe die
geht immer noch nicht raus alleine sind
über 80 Jahre sind Risiko Patienten und
meine beiden Brüder glauben nicht an
Corona und da gibt's immer wieder
aufeinandertreffen Probleme Streit ich
habe den Hausverbot gegeben die dürfen
meine Eltern nicht besuchen weil ich
gesagt habe ihr habt Zutritt in die
Wohnung wenn ihr die Masken trägt oder
wenn ihr einen frischen
macht ja meine Eltern waren schon
zweimal an Corona erkrankt hatten auch
Gott sei Dank haben sie überlebt aber
ich möchte kein Risiko mehr eingehen
weil irgendjemand abergläubig ist nicht
an Corona glaubt diese diese
Krankheit ist nicht mit einer normalen
Grippe zu vergleichen verdammt ich bin
selber erkrankt ich wusste gar nicht ob
ich noch am Leben bleibe so schlimm ging
es mir ich hatte auch seelische
psychische wirklich Probleme Schmerzen
danach das hat sich bis drei vier bis
ein halbes Jahr hat sich das angehalten
ne und keiner kann sich in die Lage
versetzen von einem Menschen der einen
schweren Verlauf hatte und ich bin echt
müde davor geworden immer wieder aufs
Neue Menschen zu erklären Leute es gibt
Corona und da habe ich auch natürlich
einige Freunde verloren auf die ich auch
gerne heute verzichte und auch mit
meinem Brüdern spreche ich nicht mehr
weil die denken ich würde übertreiben
die haben mir noch bis jetzt keine
Corona gehabt ich habe gesagt okay dann
werden wir uns vielleicht einmal oder
zweimal im Jahr treffen ich nehme das in
Kauf Hauptsache meine Eltern leben
vielleicht noch paar Jahre und dann sind
sie tot aber wie lange wollen Sie das
aufrecht erhalten also bis zum Tod
bis zum Schluss bin ich radikal geworden
weil wer nicht das respektiert das
ältere Menschen riesige gefährdeter sind
als junge Leute der muss einfach gerade
meine Geschwister ich habe immer wieder
soft und Streit und manchmal spreche ich
mit dem bitte nur mit Maske die Eltern
besuchen und so ich lege einfach den
Hörer auf ich habe einfach satt immer
mich zu rechtfertigen und zu erklären es
ist nicht mit einer Grippe zu
vergleichen verdammt Herr Bonelli genau
das sind ja auch sehr interessiert diese
diese Risse die durch Freundschaften die
durch Familien gehen die sind da
und haben sie eine Empfehlung wie kann
man überhaupt diese Risse wie sehr
leiden in ihrer Eltern auch doch meine
Eltern leiden sehr ich leider auch sehr
aber dann frage ich mich wenn Menschen
jemand Menschen besuchen und auch lieben
das sind auch die Eltern ne von von von
Geschwistern dann müssen Sie einfach mal
verdammt in der Lage sein für eine
Stunde die Maske aufzusetzen
verhärtet wie kann man verteilen also
das kann man heilen indem man alle auf
einen Tisch bringt oder indem man eben
versucht sich gegenseitig Wert zu
schätzen und seine eigene Meinung auch
ein bisschen zu relativieren und
aufeinander zu hören hier ist natürlich
wichtig was wollen Eltern also ich
erlebe relativ ich erlebe relativ häufig
dass
ältere Menschen abgeschirmt werden von
einem von einer von einem Kind und die
anderen Kinder und die leiden darunter
dass die anderen Kinder nicht dort sein
dürfen weil sie Regeln aufstellen und
glaube ich da muss man schon einen
Kompromiss finden
Beispiele einer meiner Patientin hat ein
Kind bekommen aber die aber ein Teil der
Familie hat ihr verboten das Kind der
Urgroßmutter zu zeigen 95 die wollte das
Kind sehen aber es hat sich halt jemand
dazwischen sozusagen zwischengeschaltet
das darfst du nicht das darfst du nicht
weil sie risikopterien ist 95 ja klar
aber
das Kind war ja der wichtiger als dass
sie noch ein paar Wochen lebt sie wollte
noch ihren Urenkel sehen
wir jetzt hier auch in diesem Beispiel
durch Familien durch die Gesellschaft
durch Freundschaften Herr lute was sie
haben Kinder sind sie denn besser durch
diese Krise durchgekommen ich selbst
oder die Kinder alle gemeinsam als
Familie was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
willst du auch noch mal in dieser Zahl
festhalten weil die 73% finde ich
schockierend wenn ich denke dass es
unseren Kindern und Jugendlichen so geht
wir haben in der Tat anfangs sehr viel
damit zu tun gehabt narrativen zu
begegnen die da verbreitet worden ja
also dieses wenn du hustest bringst du
die Oma um ja das waren ja Sachen die
tatsächlich Kindern von Personen von
denen sie eigentlich gelernt haben dass
man den vertrauen soll dass sie
informiert sind dass sie eine
wahrheitsgemäße Informationen
übermitteln
zum Beispiel alle Schulen Vergleiche mit
Ratten etc dramatische dramatische Dinge
die dort mit den Seelen der Kinder
geschehen sind
den man Verantwortung und das ist nach
wie vor es ist schlichtweg lächerlich zu
sagen ja von dem oder dem habe ich mich
da oder da angesteckt das ist
bekanntermaßen das brauchen wir
wissenschaftlich nicht drüber reden
vollkommener Unfug es steht auf einem
Virus nicht drauf wo sie das hier haben
ja vollkommener Quatsch trotzdem wurde
ein solcher Schuldkult damit betrieben
und das hat Kinder massiv belastet weil
sie eben halt auch nicht mehr frei
miteinander interagieren konnten und
weil sie sich eben halt in der Tat
gefragt haben Mensch der oder der ist
jetzt krank bin ich vielleicht auch noch
Schuld und jetzt stellen wir uns noch
mal vor die 95-Jährige Großmutter oder
Urgroßmutter wäre dann verstorben
unterfragt sich das Kind trage ich daran
Schuld nein selbstverständlich nicht
aber es ist in einem bemerkenswerten
massenpsychologischen Phänomen von allen
Seiten diesen Kindern eingeredet worden
also die Schäden finde ich in der
tatatisch wir haben eben halt
tatsächlich bei uns zumindest die
Möglichkeit gehabt rational über die
Dinge zu reden ja zu erklären wo besteht
was besteht welche Gefahr das
beispielsweise eben in der Tat eine
Vergleichbarkeit mit dem griffevirus
versterblichkeit angeht herrscht wissen
wir mittlerweile da sind anfangs ich
habe das ja im Abgeordnetenhaus damals
in Debatten unmittelbar miterlebt war
von der Sterblichkeit von zwischen 10
und 15 Prozent gesprochen das war
übrigens auch der Moment in dem ich im
März 2020 gesagt hätte vielleicht sind
das Masken gar keine schlechte Idee mit
dem Stand den man damals hatte einen
Monat später zwei Monate später drei
Monate später hatte man schon ganz
andere Erkenntnisse erst recht ein Jahr
später und wir haben bis viel zu lange
durchgezogen haben in der Generation von
Kindern belastet die nicht ungezwungen
miteinander aufwachsen konnten die
teilweise gar nicht gelernt haben sich
eben halt auch im Schulunterricht
miteinander auszutauschen weil das ja
auch lange virtuell stattfand und die
jetzt erst mühsam und im übrigen mit dem
geschwächten Immunsystem wird das Masken
tragen weil sie eben halt gar keine
Abwehrreaktionen entwickeln konnten
jetzt neu in Krankheiten reinlaufen wir
haben massiv dort eingegriffen dass ich
Gott sei Dank muss mir das nicht
vorwerfen aber es ist jetzt dringend an
der Seite bin ich völlig bei ihnen
darüber zu sprechen wie man eine
Schließung dieses Risses wieder
hinbekommen kann aber nicht mit einem
Schwamm drüber konnte man nicht wissen
wie jetzt einige Leute sagen sondern in
der Tat wenn ich darüber nachgedacht
hätte hätte ich es wissen sollen es darf
sich nicht noch einmal wiederholen der
Start ist dafür verantwortlich Lockdown
die Schulschließungen muss jetzt der
Staat auch die Mittel zur Verfügung
stellen den Kindern zu helfen also der
Staat hat es verbockt und der Staat wird
es nicht reparieren ich sag's mal so
hart und ich glaube dass die ganze
Misere über die wir da sprechen die hat
mit dem Staat insofern was zu tun als
die wie soll ich sagen dieses ständige
betiteln unseres ganzen Lebens durch den
Staat die hat dazu geführt dass die
Menschen mit Risiken nicht mehr
vernünftig umgehen können und auch wenn
ich niemandem in seine eigenen Erfahrung
zu nahe treten möchte so ist es ein
riesiger Unterschied ob man ein Risiko
an der eigenen Erfahrung fest macht oder
ob es tatsächlich wissenschaftlich mit
anderen Worten statistisch unterlegt ist
und es gibt auch bei Grippe schwere
Verläufe die gibt's man stirbt auch an
Grippe in der unter bestimmten Umständen
also alte Leute sterben Krippe und es
gab in der Vergangenheit auch immer
Grippewellen ohne dass wir wie soll ich
sagen die Gesellschaft an den Rand des
Zusammenbruchs geführt hätten aber wir
haben uns daran gewöhnt dass sämtliche
Risiken die wir wahrnehmen vom Staat uns
abgenommen werden gemanagt werden vom
Staat und wenn dann der Staat in seiner
sag mal Machtvollkommenheit und
Übergriffigkeit und zum Teil auch Hybris
ein Risiko komplett falsch einschätzt
oder wenn er dazu getrieben wird ein
Risiko komplett falsch einzuschätzen
dann ist es Ergebnis dass die Menschen
dem nachrennen dem Glauben weil sie ja
quasi ihre Risiko Verantwortlichkeit
seit Jahren an den Staat delegiert haben
und so funktioniert's aber nicht wir
müssen endlich mal wieder lernen selbst
Risiken einzuschätzen und wenn wir ein
Fehler gemacht haben und das war ein
Fehler und wir haben an dieser Stelle
als Gesellschaft überhaupt nicht
evidenzbasiert gehandelt denn im Grunde
genommen war schon seit früher 2020 klar
dass die Sterblichkeit nicht so sind wie
man es erstmal befürchtet hatte übrigens
interessant an der Stelle wenn man sich
im April 2020 die sterblichkeitsquoten
der einzelnen europäischen Länder
angeschaut hat und die man miteinander
verglichen hat aber festgestellt dass
die von 0,02 Prozent bis 13 Prozent in
die Systeme reingemeldet haben also eine
riesige Spannweite und interessant auch
dass die Sterblichkeit die gemeldet wird
umso höher war je höher die
Staatsverschuldung eines Landes war also
die Länder mit der höchsten
Staatsverschuldung haben die höchste
Sterblichkeit angeblich gehabt kann man
nachrechnen wenn man in die Statistiken
und vor allem auch bei meiner Frage wer
soll jetzt helfen wenn sie sagen der
Staat kann es nicht regeln was können
wir tun damit diese Kinder
73%, die mit psychischen Folgen zu
kämpfen haben weil sie nicht in die
Schule gehen dürften weil sie keinen
Kontakt zu Freunden hatten weil nicht
weil der Spielplatz offen war weil sie
zu Hause saßen und kein Kontakt Schule
ist ein soziales Gefüge nicht nur zum
Lernen und jetzt darunter liegen wir uns
falsch gemacht erwachsen hin oder her
und es darf nicht wieder passieren
also ich bin kein Psychologe kann ich
einschätzen wie Psychologen da helfen
können dass der Bonelli sicher besser
als ich aber ich glaube in aller erster
Linie mal müssen wir wieder zu einem
familiären zusammen sein zurückfinden
dass das allerwichtigste und deswegen
glaube ich dass jede jeder Gedanke
erstmal darauf ausgerichtet sein sollte
wie man den familiären Zusammenhang
Zusammenhalt wieder stärkt und alles was
das stört gehört eigentlich weg und dann
muss ich Ihnen auch ehrlich sagen da
verstehe ich ihre Haltung nicht für
absolutieren Sie nicht Ihre eigene
Erfahrung sondern was sagt die
Wissenschaft die Wissenschaft sagt wir
haben eine Sterblichkeit die
vergleichbar ist mit der Krippe und ja
auch Grippe kann schlimm sein und ja wir
haben alle Ängste und ja wir versuchen
alle mit riesigen umzugehen aber wir
sollten es wieder rational machen
brauchen wir mehr Psychologen musste
Starter auch mehr Geld zur Verfügung
stellen man hat warte listen hier in
Deutschland sie haben in Österreich aber
man hat warte dass man kriegt nicht so
schnell einen Therapeuten der helfen
kann
nämlich ganz wichtig die
angstkommunikation wenn ein Kind erlebt
dass die dass das alle Angst haben
fürchterlich Angst haben dann dann
überträgt sich das auf das Kind nicht
also wir wissen das von den Helikopter
Müttern und Helikopter Vätern dass die
eine Angst in das Kind produzieren dass
das Kind glaubt alles ist gefährlich und
genauso war Corona in Corona hatten die
Erwachsenen so viel Angst und haben die
Kinder so stark eingeschränkt dass die
Kinder zu leiden begonnen haben also das
ist glaube ich das erste und das zweite
ist dass sie vom sozialen Leben
weggeschnitten wurden hin zum virtuellen
Leben weil natürlich der Internetkonsum
und der computerkonsum ist halt extrem
gewachsen und ich habe Kinder in der
Praxis oder er Erzählungen von Eltern
ich bin Erwachsenen Psychiater dass die
Kinder eigentlich von dem Apparat gar
nicht mehr wegkommen und auch nicht mehr
wollen und sich auch nicht mehr
interessieren für alle Frauen über ihre
Freunde sind jetzt virtuell also ich
glaube da ist ein riesiger Schaden und
da müssen wir da müssen wir hinschauen
wenn sie jetzt sagen flächendeckend
Psychologen ja ich meine ich wohne halt
jetzt in Wien mit der höchsten
Psychotherapeuten Dichte in auf der
ganzen Welt würde ich mal sagen
aber und ich finde man kann es auch
übertreiben also wichtig ist dass wir
ein Umfeld schaffen wo wir wo wo wo
normale Familie sich normal entwickeln
kann glaube ich das ist wesentlich und
und nicht das alles sofort Therapeut
therapiert wird weil wir weil wir
produzieren sonst Patienten es gibt ja
schon eben auch
psychotherapiegeschädigte nicht die die
aus dieser aus diesem aus dieser Nummer
der Psychotherapie gar nicht rauskommen
ich will es nicht gegen meinen Fach
sprechen aber man kann es auch
übertreiben nicht deswegen ich glaube
wir brauchen ganz viel Normalität und
die hat gefehlt in den letzten drei
Jahren